[Music]
this is sog cast
number six
my name is j striker meyer and i'm
joined by tom the technician
and welcome to the show
they move quietly through the darkness
they have planned for months and chosen
this day
august 23rd
1968
and timed carefully
everything was as their informants had
said it would be
and now all that was left was execution
various elements broke off to their
assigned positions
machine guns in place
satchel charges at the ready
they waited for the signal
let slip the dogs of war
private first class john e peers found
himself crawling on the floor
he had been blown out of his bed
literally by explosions in the camp
ordinarily
this would not be unusual after a night
of heavy drinking
but peters could hear massive explosions
all around the hooch
and burst a small arms fire
ripping through the darkness
his mind worked frantically
where exactly was he and where the hell
was his weapon
private first class william h brick iii
grabbed his web gear and car 15
shout some words that did not make sense
to peters and charged out the door
to his assigned defensive position
sappers were unquestionably the elite
troops in the nba
sappers received six months of
concentrated training
tonight on this night august the 23rd
they were fanatically dedicated troops
and their missions were often
self-destructive
they were the purveyors of unbridled
mayhem
and on this night they struck with
southern fury
the enemy launched an intense barrage 82
mortimeter
fire at fob4
from somewhere behind
st rattler as soon as the situation
permitted larry trimble made his way
towards the south side of the mountain
with several of his known team members
and as we had on a previous broadcast
larry tremble was one of our guests and
spoke about that night
today i want to say we're privileged to
have john peters
with us
he survived that night and served in mac
visage john welcome to the show thank
you very much it's a great pleasure to
be here and to be just to be
after that night indeed
there were doubts and for our viewing
audience august 23rd 1968 the
nva sappers
and viet cong sappers had planned the
attack for over a year
they struck in the early morning hours
of august the 23rd
and at the top secret base which was a
mcv sog base
and
they had planned it well
and they had we had extra personnel in
camp that night there was a promotion
board along with the regular men that
were stationed there and then they also
had a command and control
monthly meeting that had been held on
base also
and it was a moonless night
so that was the night and uh like you
said with your
uh opening line there uh fortunately you
had been drinking intoxicated and you
couldn't figure out where you were but
in a way that played to your
indeed
advantage
did it was
a night to remember and
sometimes you don't want to remember
those kinds of things but that was
certainly
one that's hard to get out of your mind
as you mentioned it was an incredibly
well planned
operation
and in that respect there was something
almost admirable about it i mean they
had their intelligence
and when they came through
they set up almost as if they had
planned this to the extent of had a
model of our compound and knew exactly
where to put the machine guns for the
clearest and most effective lines of
fire
they knew exactly what they wanted to do
and they were there to do it
i have never heard a clear estimation of
how many of them there were
but i've heard estimates from four to
six hundred and maybe upwards of that
which meant that they outnumbered the
people in the compound probably
five or six to one
and so
certainly caught us by surprise you said
some of us were there for a promotion
ceremony i was
and of course what ceremony of any kind
can pass without a few drinks amongst
the special forces types
and so we did indeed share some drinks
and i went back to the hooch that i was
sharing with
bill brick
he had been kind enough to offer me that
said i didn't have to stay in the
transit barracks because we'd been in a
training group together
and so that's how i wound up there and
fob4 had a reputation of being so safe
that
some of us
me and certainly
uh decided it was so safe there was no
need for me to bring my car 15 my web
gear and the normal you know things with
you know with grenades and all the stuff
we normally carry
i went down with simply a 45 caliber
pistol
and
bill told me he said well there's been a
rash not a rash but he says there's been
some pistols stolen he said so
what i want you to do
when you go off is put it in the foot
locker here and we'll lock it up and
that way nobody will steal it
and i thought well that's a brilliant
idea you know so i you know
put the 45 in there and uh said okay you
know see you later but as i left i said
you know he was there sitting at a desk
with a a a lamp on writing and i said
well you know come on bill come on with
me and and let's have a drink you know i
haven't seen you in a while he said no
no no you go on you go on he said i'm
writing a letter to my girlfriend
um and to this day i've often wondered
you know what happened to that letter
okay you know and um it was you know
thinking back on it that was the last
moment of me seeing him alive was
you know sitting there with his head
down writing so i left
and of course we had the full night of
fun yeah so let me just go back to that
one point in time then please do it yeah
yeah sure this is we're going back to
the book on the ground
and uh as pfc brick dashed out of his
hooch to confront the enemy
peters still on all fours
suddenly recrawled where his weapon was
it wasn't particularly comforting like a
number of others peters had traveled to
da nang just for that reason for the
promotion board and his 45 was safely
locked up
and then peters found himself in a
vulnerable position
hooches were blowing up around him and
bullets were hitting the one he was in
he needed to join up with other
survivors and organize some kind of
defense as or a counterattack
he also needed something other than a 45
if he was gone to survive or make any
kind of meaningful
contribution to the fight
as he surveyed the chaotic scene he saw
a group flying from inside a small
sandbag enclosure next to the hooch
diagonally across from him
he couldn't tell for sure how many there
were or who they were
but he assumed they were americans
taking no chances he yelled across to
them to let them know where he was
and that he was going to try and reach
them
they would cover him while he made his
sprint
just a few meters outside was a body
with a car 15 and some ammo pouches on
the ground next to it
as peter stood
to gather these
he was shocked to see
it was bill brick lying motionless in
the sand he had been gunned down by the
nva
as soon as he rushed outside
had peter's been able to respond as
quickly
and as surely as brick had
he would have been lying next to him
peter's hesitated but then picked up
brick's weapon and ammo
and quietly thanked him
with bullets cracking past him and sand
kicking up all around
peter's completed his mad dash to the
enclosure
and then um
maybe talk a little bit because
the there were three rows of hooches in
the recon area and in front of each one
there are sidewalks
and the nva placed machine guns so when
men like bill brick came out those
machine guns were waiting for him yeah
my understanding is that a lot of most
of the casualties took place rather
immediately
just because of that now bill was
assigned to the fob so he had a position
that he was supposed to go to
uh in a situation like that so he knew
what he needed to do and he
god bless him he you know he didn't
hesitate he grabbed his gear
and he and he rushed out to do his do
his duty um and of course they were
waiting for him outside the door
uh i was left behind still trying to
figure out how i was going to get my 45
and i found the foot locker and sure
enough it had a lock on it well a big
big surprise
and i used a knife to pry the
lock open and got my
45 and then i literally low crawl to the
door so that i could look out and that's
when i kind of surveyed the situation
and so as you can hear bullets ripping
through your oh yeah that was uh yeah
you know those those hooches were made
out of plywood and so there wasn't a lot
of resistance there
um
and so yeah i mean i can't you know you
people talk about the sounds of bullets
as they pass you you know well i don't
know but you know something was flying
around
and i knew i needed to get out of there
and get someplace that would because
what the nva were doing is they were
making their way down the rows of
hooches and picking them off kind of one
at a time with satchel charges
uh the hooches had air conditioning air
conditioners uh in in
holes in the wall and then what they
were doing was kicking in the air
conditioners or pushing them in and then
throwing satchel charges into the hooch
or whatever wherever it was
and and you could kind of tell that was
what was coming so we you know you
needed to get out of there and get
somewhere else
and that's what i made my dash i could
see that there was something
going on across the way that looked
promising
so i
yeah i said okay that's where i guess i
gotta go next
and um yeah and then i went out and as
as it says in the book that's when i
found him
um
he took his weapon and the ammo that was
there
and joined the other fellas who were in
this sandbag enclosure
uh small sandbag enclosure
and that's where i took up my first
position for the night
yes that's the one where the
sandbag machine gun and placement
there was like hardly room for the four
of them to stand much less kraus
and this was a problem because the
sandbags
reached only chest high in effect the
enclosure offered no meaningful
protection
because all four of them could not duck
down at the same time
however from the new vantage point
peters could observe a steady
crisscrossing of enemy troops some had
their bodies wrapped with explosives and
many carried satchel charges and baskets
or grenades along with their ak-47s
it was clear they had come prepared for
a long night
like many of those around him peters had
operated in the chaos of jungle warfare
where
unexpected things happened quickly and
at close quarters
but he never seen a large-scale battle
like the one
currently raging around him
peters was brought out of his days by a
sapper who was running across in front
of him firing his ak-47 as he ran
peters fired a short burst from bricks
car 15
and the sapper pissed forward to his
knees his forehead resting in the sand
like a muslim in prayer
he never fell over and for the rest of
the night
peters could see
his near naked body bowed over
as if offering
a final homage to whatever brought him
to this place on that night
in this semi-exposed position peter's
his group made inviting targets
and so drew their share of attention
including periodic volleys of grenades
that had to be returned
in a bizarre twist of fate
that none of them had anticipated
their protective enclosure
began dribbling away around them
at first they couldn't figure out what
was going on
and then it hit them as more and more
rounds hit the sandbags the bags
steadily deflated as the sand ran out
time to find new cover
oh my god john
yeah that reads almost like a woody
allen movie yeah
you know yeah we there we were and um
and thought we were
okay we're not okay but i mean we
thought well this is about the best we
can do it seems pretty secure
um we did have the problem of people
throwing grenades at us and you know we
had to do something about that so he
generally picked him up threw him back
uh or caught him and threw him back
um
but you know as you looked out it was
like somebody had kicked over a
rock or something and cockroaches were
scurrying around because
the light was provided by overhead
flares which are very provide a very
unusual kind of light that lacks depth
perception and has a certain quality to
it especially over sand it was a very
very eerie looking thing and you could
see these
black forms scurrying back and forth in
all kinds of directions and you really
couldn't tell who
you know except the ones that were well
even the ones that didn't have much
clothes on you weren't sure whether
those were your own people who had been
come out of bed right not fully dressed
or distant truth to who responded that's
right and and of course we had our
indigenous personnel there who many of
them look very much like the enemy and
so
you know there was a massive problem in
just trying to sort out well who's who
and what am i supposed to do
but anyway yeah we were in the sandbags
and um
everything was going as it was going and
then we noticed that you know i'm like i
said short you know and
you know suddenly the sandbag was lower
and lower on my body and i was trying to
figure out you know what in the world is
going on here and then it dawned on us
that you know what was happening was we
were taking so much fire that the
sandbags were you know giving out on us
and so yeah um yeah we then said okay
well let's get out of here and let's go
somewhere else and so we more or less
went in different directions because
uh you didn't want to clump together
yeah you know so in a very short period
of time it goes from a quiet night yeah
you're asleep yeah and just begin to
sleep off a little too much alcohol
right and it just goes to this
apocalyptic death scene yes with so much
going on with enemy running around and
then the additional spectre of not being
able to delineate clearly enemy from
our allies or south vietnamese or even
the yards that were there because
they're the same stature yeah and some
of the guys like like i don't know how
much clothing you had on you left a
hooch but some guys just ran out with
the shorts on absolutely without shoes
there were people going around yeah and
to this day it's a terrible thing to
have to try to contemplate and i you
know i have it for any depth because i
don't know the answer but there had to
have been some friendly fire casualties
that night there had to there had to
have been in all that confusion some of
our own troops
you know killed by mistake and that's
that's terribly sad but
as far as i could tell there's
absolutely no way around it in a
situation like that i mean it's really
hard to describe the level of chaos
um you know and and and as as the book
said you know we were used to being out
in the jungle where you could see how
far in front of you 10 15 feet or
something and if if if you got into
trouble you know you often couldn't see
clearly who it was it was shooting at
you i mean right you know you you
returned fire to where you it sounded
like it was coming from or wherever you
thought you ought to be shooting
but this was absolutely unique because
it was a flat beach
type thing
white sand
illuminated by flares
and you could see in great detail
the chaos
the mayhem the death and then the flares
would come and go so you wouldn't have a
constant light you'd have a light that
would be surreal it would go out and
then a new flare would come up with a
different angle with a different look
yeah and you had like to reassess
where you were again in terms of enemy
good guys and whatever yeah and the the
elimination flares are just that flares
and they're they're hung underneath the
parachute and of course as they come
down they start swaying back and forth
and so you know it's like if you're in a
room with a suspended light bulb and
somebody hits the light bulb and it
starts swinging back and forth and you
know your shadow is shifting
position constantly and everybody else's
shadows are
shifting position constantly and they're
shifting position constantly physically
and so i mean
the very idea of trying to take aim and
shoot at somebody was very problematic
because were you shooting at the shadow
are you shooting at them were you
shooting where the shadow was and it
isn't anymore i don't know these are
paper targets these no no no
these are moving targets and shifting
shadows and all of that kind of stuff
and lots of noise smells
um
you know it was um like i said it was
pretty chaotic and uh
you know um yeah
so you move from the sandbags to a more
secure position then yeah we
we you weren't as yeah you've more or
less fought your way that way i guess
you know they were shooting along the
way oh yeah and uh you know you tried to
you tried to estimate
you find yourself in a
well an interesting position because
you know being human you wanted to save
your own self but then being part of a
group part of a team you wanted to
contribute your
you know your bit and so you're you know
you'd find a place that looked like well
that would be yeah that's a good place
to hide but then you really didn't want
to hide you know you wanted to be some
in some situation where you can
contribute so it was a it was a the rest
of the night was
a constant moving around you know you
would be in one place for a while and
then
you know you'd think well maybe i've got
to ought to go over there and see what's
happening
um you know yeah so for a lot more
details or in the book about that but in
your case one of the other
aspects was sun light finally came up
and then you also had
a final encounter with a couple of enemy
correct correct yeah that was i believe
they were they were said to be the last
enemy kill that
throughout the event it was early the
following morning the sun hadn't been up
that
long
and i joined a group of people well and
when i started i think there were only
two of us and we were doing kind of like
a sweep through the camp if you will to
try to see if we could find any
you know remaining
nba in the camper enemy
and as we were walking along um
suddenly these two guys
came you know um bursting out of some
rubble
um and it didn't take long to see that
there was this is in the recon company
area yeah that they were no this was uh
further down uh further down
away from it uh okay west of it right um
and um
they were making this mad dash and it
was cl you know it became
very clear that they were enemy because
they were dressed in their loin claws
and had their you know what they had
anyway they ran into an outhouse that
was there you know latrine well i would
like right an outhouse but a tree made
out of plywood usually a two seater or
three no this was this was a deluxe
model
yeah i had six seats it was quite large
i think i had six i never counted them
but i think there were six seats
somewhere in there
i didn't i stayed at a fart yeah i
wasn't i wasn't i wasn't assigned to
that so i would did not have this
intimate acquaintance with the latrines
that's right you're a visitor yeah that
i should have had perhaps but anyway
they both disappear into the um into the
train we'll call it and uh so i mean
what's a man to do so i just opened up
you know and fired a full clip into the
into the cardboard structure i mean the
cardboard the plywood structure and the
guy that was with me also fired some
shots
and you know it doesn't take long to
empty a uh you know magazine of
a car 15 a second and a hand yeah you
rip through that pretty quickly yes so
there really wasn't much time that
elapsed between the last shot and
suddenly the entire thing exploded the
latrine the latrine did they set off the
explosives that were wrapped around
their bodies
and i this is an image that i know that
you know whenever i think of it i see
the exact same thing and it was like
and i'm sure everybody see it and seen
it in action movies when something blows
up and a character or a person comes
kind of a slow motion flying out of it
flying through the air without the
greatest of ease yeah flying through the
and that's exactly what it was this body
came
flying out of the of what was the
latrine and sailed and landed about i
don't know five or six feet in front of
me
and you know is then that i could see
that well there wasn't much of a person
left there i mean you know that they'd
had explosive wrapped around him so you
know what finally landed on the ground
in front of me was not you know
recognizable as a human being more never
already um but anyway yeah that i've
always that that is an image that is
just stick hard to get out of your mind
yeah
and so then we moved on and other people
joined us uh and we the group and we did
the sweep
and um
verified there was nobody else you know
left trying to kill us
and went about then
trying to put order back into the chaos
you know indeed getting
pick up the bodies yeah that was the
worst of it
because they were everywhere and um
and and
i don't know what kind of a thing it is
to say but i was lucky in the sense that
i wasn't from there so i didn't
recognize aside from bill brick i didn't
recognize any of the dead yeah because
you and bill had
been made contact previously we were in
in uh training group training group okay
and i had and
so so you know there was there was a i
could maintain an emotional distance if
you will
from what i was seeing and what was
going on but certainly some of the
people who were with me you know it's
very very difficult
to do that oh yeah i can't imagine and
and while you're doing it there's
running through your mind why them and
not me
i mean the most remarkable thing to come
out of that kind of experience i think
and i think we touch on it a lot in the
book
and that is the extent to which just
pure blind luck
you know is accountable for so much i
mean you can have all the all the
training in the world
you can be the baddest dude on the block
right you know and if things don't break
just right
you know that's it
and you know there's no i mean i don't
know i mean that's you know i certainly
didn't deserve to live that night
anymore than a lot of other people
deserved it many people probably
deserved more
but um yeah
yeah and like that contrast between what
happened to bill brick yeah he's
reporting the duty where he's got he's
told to go he's gunned down immediately
yeah upon leaving the team hooch
and then compared to
the other side a few doors down where
john walton and ron padlaski
were in their hooch
and they were putting on their boots
yeah and then an nva came by to throw a
satchel charge into the hooch but that
was the one i remember that door
because it was strongly strung yeah so
that when they opened it the spring
closed the door quickly so quickly that
the nva thrown the sassa charge and
didn't get it inside hit the door lands
blows up the staircase yeah that will
stare three or four stairs leading into
the hooch and then when jon and ron come
out they literally fall over each other
because there's no steps yeah
my wife described that kind of door for
me in the south it's going as a batman
scream door bamming screen door and you
know every country home used to have
them and you know your mother was
constantly screaming at you don't slam
the door you know because the kid would
push it open and keep going and the door
would slam behind them well this one had
this spring was so tight that when the
as i picture it because i wasn't there
but the nva yanked it open and thought
he was going to you know follow up and
throw the sacral charge through the open
screen door and the screen door closed
so fast that the satchel charge bounced
off of it
and blew up right outside their hooch
and that took out the steps and so yeah
when they finally got their boots
problems straightened out
and that was kind of funny i mean two
you know one guy's waiting for the other
one to put on his boots yes he's got one
oven's got one boot on and can't figure
out what to do with the other boot
allegedly he goes through a thought
process as well should i take off the
boot i have on or should i put on the
boat that i don't have on or should i
take both yeah i mean it was
one of these decision trees that he was
running through and meanwhile john
walton's waiting yeah come come on come
on and so when they finally when they
finally get the boots on he gets the
boots on and they go out the door you
know it's like again it's like a
one of those road runner cartoons or
something they step out of the hooch
expecting that they're going to step
onto a step that was there yeah and it's
not there anymore and it's so you know
they just
we've all had that sinking feeling where
you step at a place where you think
there's going to be support and there is
none and so they both fell to the ground
and an nvi nba was out there and he was
immediately shot but because he shot
where he thought they were going to be
and of course they were where you know
nobody was where they thought they were
going to be yeah you know and that saved
their life i mean you know there they
were on the sand you know and uh
i i believe uh one of the indigenous
people or something like that came along
at just the opportune moment because
you know the guys on the sand were in no
position to take out the right the guy
and somebody came along and and did it
for them and so they could rally
themselves and
and move again
that second by my new second by second
moment yeah had the other end did not
come along and taken out that gunner who
was killing anybody coming out of the
hooches yeah all in a matter of seconds
yeah oh yeah less than i mean yeah it's
in micro seconds micro seconds indeed
and uh yeah that's
well again there's a lot more of that
story that's in the book
and that um i'm proud to say that we
co-authored and uh um
but one of the
other amazing stories is one of my
favorites from chapter 15
entitled one lucky day where
you sir
could have been dead at least three
times
without trying too hard and nary a shot
was fired by the enemy correct
and uh i just want to set the scene a
little bit because one of our missions
was the elder sun where we would take in
ammunition to an enemy site and drop it
off to the enemy pick it up and blow
himself up that was the plan
and
you were on one of these elder sun
missions
this is oh and we should close with the
fob-4 attack the final body count we
lost 16 green berets that night
on the morning of august the 23rd which
to this day is still the highest single
loss of green berets in sf history
tragically and uh
dozens of indigenous people were killed
and then the we're still working on a
final number for the number of nba that
were killed of course
some
um
were carried off as they often are by
their
by their counterparts yeah there was
actually you bring that up there were
surprisingly few uh enemy bodies left
and i you know there were blood trails
leading out of the compound where
obviously some that had been wounded it
had retreated to wherever they came from
and then some had been dragged away but
i mean
i don't think there's any doubt that the
body count for them must have numbered
in the hundreds
i mean there's no way because with
spooky there working out with the
gunship that came in and was firing with
all the rest of the stuff that was going
on yeah they they had to suffer heavy
casualties yeah because one of the
gunships came in right when
the nva sappers were attempting because
right next door
to fob4 was an nva power yeah encampment
which had over a thousand enemy soldiers
imprisoned yeah
and they were trying to get through to
them and fortunately the gunship got
there and somebody was able to direct
enough fire
that they weren't able because if that
those thousand enemy troops had been
sprung loose
well the the the
i've heard that that was one of their
major objectives that they wanted to
free the thousand who would then join up
with them and then there would be a
sweep further inland i mean this was all
during the tet
offensive this was a this was part of
tet
uh most people think of tet as just one
battle but it was a year-long series of
battles uh that were more or less worked
its way north to south
and this was part of that activity i'm
quite sure and so that yeah they had big
plans for that night
um and i was about to say it i mean if
anybody asked me
how did how did you win
i don't know yeah i mean sun sunrise
came and it seemed to be over
you know and
and given the odds and given the fact
that we had nothing resembling an
organized response
i mean it was really literally
pick a number you know a dozen two dozen
five dozen individual
fire fights going on in this compound
you know and you could kind of it was
kind of like it was an invitation only
but you could go around and join in you
know as i moved along i mean i joined in
and some firefights that were ongoing i
mean okay you come across one join in
you know and then keep moving you know
and it was bizarre i mean
you know and just can't imagine yeah and
stuff was blowing up because the supply
depot got hit and i don't know how many
tons of stuff went up c4
grenades everything else and that was
like a
you know that was like the mother of all
bombs going off because it was just huge
a huge explosion knocked people off
their feet and some people were were
hurt seriously as a result of that a
wall collapsed on somebody right and was
killed but i mean yeah all that stuff
was going on meanwhile helicopters are
overhead doing stuff
uh you know spooky's flying around doing
what he's doing
uh you know there's yelling and they're
screaming and nobody really knows what's
going on at all
so again if asked how in the world did
we
quote win
i mean i'm not saying we won but i mean
somehow it came to an end
and i don't know whether you know how
that happened i'm happy it did but i
don't know
i don't know how it happened and uh
as we
had detailed much more detail in sog
cast number five with larry trimble our
last guest yes um
larry was up on the mountain and he took
out the enemy mortar tubes yeah and his
recon team as well as
uh fending off several attacks on their
position by the via kong and va up there
and had not been for that there would
have been much more
casualties amongst our friendly troops
yeah at f1b4 yeah
yeah it was uh yeah there you have it
indeed well moving on to a day where you
should have been dead three times
or at least been in deep trouble at
least deep do do uh return to chapter 15
one lucky day
and again this was uh
you were going to insert the eldest
and
so you were out there you transferred
from fob one could be closed for b1
in january
and uh our team went down to da nang
fob4 which became ccn you went to khan
tomb but you went down as a freelance
correct by yourself without a team right
because i was very close to my duros the
day in which i was to leave vietnam and
return home
and so um you know i
got separated from rt rhode island who
had been with
and wound up there and
while i was there i helped run the
launch site and did some strap hanging
as we call i kind of volunteered to go
out on things and this was one of those
cases they were going to run an elder
sun mission and those missions
correct me if i'm wrong but i think they
were always all american
i don't remember hearing about the
indigenous and i don't know whether
because that was a it was a special
level of secrecy because i was also told
theoretically it was against the geneva
code to put doctored ammunition
you know back into the hands of the
enemy to ruin their day
uh you know and you know and none of us
who were engaged in it felt bad about it
at all
yeah but i thought there was a certain
level of absurdity there because i kept
thinking
somebody and maybe you can because i
don't know the answer to this somehow
that ammunition got taken out of
laos
or cambodia by somebody
it was taken somewhere and it was
doctored
then it was brought back by somebody and
given to somebody and then somehow we
wound up with it and we were just
supposed to take it back and put it
where it came from
that was one of the unique services
because saag had their own supply system
that was based in i think okinawa system
oh okay and with uh ben baker and his
crew okay so again
the first party question i don't know
how they got the ammo to them but they
doctored it okay so that
for our viewing audience our listening
audience
when that was used by the enemy it would
explode in their face
right and and and the
the the object of it was of course to
ruin the individual's day but the more
important aspect of it was the
psychological uh aspect of undermining
their confidence in their supply system
and their weapons yeah their weapons
because if you're standing next to a guy
who you know pulls the trigger and his
weapon blows up on his face
that lessens your confidence in your own
so on that mission you were taken in
rpgs and with the border rounds for the
82 yeah
the enemy mortars were 82 millimeters
we used 81. right so they could use ours
but we couldn't use theirs yeah clever
i don't know if they intended it that
way but that's the way it worked out no
so just to go back just for a little bit
here to the book
without a team of his own peters was
left to strap hang or volunteer
so he found himself as part of an
all-american
sortie
to enter cambodia to sow the seeds of
the little eldest son meanness into the
daniel boone which was cambodia area of
operations
in this case was rpgs and mortar rounds
all of which were packed to wooden
crates
and on this day
you get to the launch site and just take
it from there because the way you tell
that story
from the from the lz once you touch down
yes because
because you you know everything's
loading the king b yeah the kb goes out
and then
take it from there yeah and then you've
got to get it out of the king be more or
less and and
you know get ready to do what you're
going to do with it but i mean you know
the no no helicopter wants to spend
unnecessary time
you know in the in the vicinity when
with something like that going on and so
we got out you know the majority of it
and there was
is that yeah one box left of mortar
rounds and so i decided well i'll take
the last box and you know take it off so
i took it out and i was walking and i
didn't get very far three or four three
or four steps and i was losing the grip
on it it was you know i didn't i hadn't
picked it up properly and so i thought
well you know i'll just set this thing
down and and um you know get a new grip
on it and so that's what i did but
unbeknownst to me the helicopter pilot
was also anxious to do his thing and so
he rose up immediately and swung
it would be to his left and that brought
the tail rotor around towards me
and i being bent down the tail rotor
passed right over me
and that was my first indication that
something dramatic has just taken place
and uh i mean because the sound of a
helicopter tail rotor passing over you
is something over your head yeah that's
something you never want to experience
and you talk about sucking all the
oxygen out of the of a room i mean that
really sucks the air it creates a kind
of vacuum over you and so you feel it in
your ears you feel it whatever and it's
got this high-pitched
you know sound that a helicopter makes a
tail rotor does
you know and then
you know and
i don't know how
well i mean i was in the act of
getting back over well i just bent over
and grabbed it the box and was just you
know getting ready to to raise up i
continued raising up i didn't know what
was going on
you know it just so happens that i
raised up after the the the
the rotor had passed over me but you
know had i again here's that microsecond
yeah had i had i literally had i
raised up you know just a
a micro second or whatever ahead of time
i would have been decapitated yeah i
would have been and yeah yeah at least
decapitated at least
so that was you know i thought well
that's a hell of a note you know indeed
yeah and meanwhile i'm looking over at
my team that i'm with you know they've
witnessed this yeah you know and they've
got this
look on their face about
horror and astonishment because you know
i mean
i wouldn't say that i don't know if they
were worried about me but i think maybe
maybe they were more worried about the
mess they would have to have dealt with
you know if that would have happened
they would have had to do something with
me you know yeah what's the impact of a
head on a tail rotor yeah not
i don't know i
have things you don't want to think
about now i've never seen it yeah i've
never seen it happen so i don't know
okay
so then a little while later
um you successfully insert right
all the banana right the eldest son
right and then you're due for an
extraction but
you can't quite get an extraction so
at some point you is it whether you're
with o'connor yeah mike
the little leprechaun his name was
michael j o'connor and he was about my
size and he was in e7 i was in the
big ad survived
august the 23rd i was in e4 that's right
you had that promotion yeah i had the
promotion and so
mike was along and um
yeah we we
we'd gotten rid of what we were you know
we we've done what we were saying
successfully inserted yes and so but the
kingbies had to go back for refueling or
something i'm not sure why they had to
leave but they did and so we had to do
something with ourselves while we waited
for them to come back so we kind of
grouped together a in a protected cover
of trees and
and whatnot and i took out my i had a
map and one of my responsibilities was
to make some notes on it so that we
could verify that we'd put it you know
where it was supposed to be and all that
stuff yeah also because after every
elder sun
insertion
it had to be recorded and then report
the headquarters in there after action
reports right right right so i i i sat
down and you know i leaned back on my
rut sack
and i think there was a slight rise
behind me that allowed me to do that
comfortably and i was leaning back
against whatever i was leaning against
and i had my i brought my knees up so
that would make my lap kind of like a
you know a lap desk and i had the map
spread there and i was kind of looking
at the map and trying to figure out what
i was supposed to be figuring out and um
i heard this yeah i'd be i'd
run i've been with
mike before and i knew him well
and i you know you can feel a certain
tension in the air when oh yeah when
things are going wrong and the pucker
factory
something keyed me in that this
all was not right
and so i looked up from the map and
mike was across from me and the look on
his face was absolutely it was a
combination of fear
uh
stark terror aghastness
i mean pick your pick your word but i
thought i you know what ran through my
mind is you know whatever it is
it's got to be awfully bad at least the
battalion or
i thought i was going to look behind me
and there was going to be an nva tank
division yeah or something like that
converging on us you know and so i
looked
you know i looked i i looked naturally
to my right and you know as i said i was
on a slight incline and i came not quite
eye to eye but almost eye to eye with a
centipede
that was about
one to two feet long yeah please
describe it because
people listening anybody in america
unless you've been in
foreign jungles
would never understand the dimensions of
this centipede i always think of a
little caterpillar when i think
centipede but yours is how long
what was it when it was
it was long
i didn't ask it to pose while i measured
it but i mean
i you know but i it was long enough
let's say that but no anybody who's been
around a true centipede there's you know
there's there's millipedes and there's
centipedes and there's various things
but you know centipedes are those things
that have all the legs that kind of
undulate when they walk they kind of
somehow move them
you know right which reminds me this is
a total break from what we're doing but
one of the best stories i've ever heard
and that was about the centipede who
allegedly had never trouble had never
had any trouble walking until somebody
asked him how he did it
[Laughter]
and that there's a lesson there and so
anyway sure yes yeah like bees they
can't fly but they do yeah it was that
kind of thing yeah but anyway yeah so he
he kind of undulated he's way past and
uh i subsequently heard that these were
so highly poisonous that that even if
they walked on your skin
you broke out in some kind of something
right really yeah you didn't die but you
you know you paid for it indeed and so
um yeah so if they did buy you finito
yeah well it was yeah i guess but anyway
yeah he he walked right along from my
shoulder down along my i had my arm i
was still holding the map and he walked
along my right arm and and when he got
about where my
where my waist was or whatever he
decided to take a right-hand turn and go
back into the jungle and uh wherever he
came from on whatever mission he was on
oh my god and uh yeah
all high off the ground like three
inches four inches oh you mean the
centipede itself yeah oh no they're
they're very flat i don't i i would
guess he probably was
he was pretty big around i said maybe
two inches yeah still but a foot and a
half two feet long yeah oh my god i've
seen pictures of him in fact i think i
sent you one of a guy holding up one
which was about four feet long
yes i've i have erased that from my mind
but you did yeah
no they they and and you know people
don't believe they exist but i'm here to
tell you they exist indeed
i almost wasn't here to tell you that
they exist but i can now tell you and
verify that their big centipedes exist
in south vietnam oh my god or and
layoffs or cambodians this was cambodia
cambodia yes it was cambodian so
so to this is all in one day
so now
that was all that was all in a couple
hours indeed yeah so
the survivor from august 23rd has these
two incidents in one day
after and welcome to 1969
so then the king bees finally come you
have a successful extraction
nothing on you you go back to consume
fob2 which was ccc
and uh which was an unusual
mcv sog top secret headquarters area for
cartoon because they literally had a
road
that drove through the center of the
camp
and
i've never had a good answer as to why
anybody would have a camp like that so
on one side
there was the housing areas on the other
side was more the operational side the
the
the clubhouse
s4 yeah blah blah so
you get back to base
a fellow recon man from fob one john t
walton the first who we mentioned
earlier
about him and ron paul alaska being so
fortunate to survive with you that night
and august 23rd
you and john gather because obviously
you had shared notes before
and you
somehow you let john talk you into a
poker game
well it was something like that yeah
i mean i i came back and you know it not
been in my house very long and was
i think i was outside and i it was mine
was next door to his so i saw he came
out of his you know and he said come on
i'm going to the club let's go over
there and
and have some drinks and play some poker
well you and i had played poker with
john before oh yeah and you know he
didn't money didn't want to do that no
you know
and you you claim this and say you saw
it that he when he had his winnings he
would take take him back to his uh
upright locker and just throw him in yes
and when you open the door money would
fall out good yes
we witnessed it once yeah because
because he he was so successful in his
in his pocket so that was my money yeah
and just and just so we're
i don't remember you discussed this
before about who he was but i mean i'll
never forget when i was when we were at
fob1 and we were just together we were
sitting on the sandbags at the perimeter
some that are out there and we're just
sitting there talking and whatever and
so we got like you will you're talking
we don't where are you from we just met
each other and i told him and where are
you from he told me
and he's you know well you know you'd go
around talk for a while and he asked me
and nobody knew where bentonville
arkansas no i see he said he was from
arkansas and then he said you know i and
he asked me what
my family did and so forth and i told
him and of course then i had to
reciprocate so i said yeah what did your
dad do he says oh you he owns a couple
of grocery stores yeah five in dime
stores yeah i said oh yeah that's all i
said because i didn't know at that time
there was no walmart no and there was
nothing i liked yeah no there was not
nothing like that so anyway but he was
and
i don't want to believe that he treated
his poker winnings that way because he
felt he was so rich but i don't think he
was he wasn't he was a very
down-to-earth guy so anyway i for i
hesitated because i hadn't really
cleaned up
and i didn't want to lose money to john
but i said okay so we went across and
like you said you had to cross the road
to the other side of the compound in
order to get to the uh watering hole
so we went there and started and it was
i i can't remember what time of night it
was it wasn't dark yet when we started
oh indeed indeed
and so one thing followed another and uh
you know we played pokemon food a little
drink a little poker poker starts you
know and then
you know that goes on and on and slowly
and people are dropping out you know
because
john's got their money oh yeah
some people actually wanted to say and
the fact you're still in a poker game
attest to you being a pretty good poker
player yeah and actually you know
some people wanted to sleep and things
like that that all that cost so we're
finally down we're finally down to me
and john and myself you know he's
already taken i think if not all of my
money very close but he's not satisfied
of course no he says so let's play gin
yeah because you're out of money now
yeah let's play gin
unfortunately i could say in all truth i
don't know how to play gin yeah
so he was disappointed
but we he said well let's have one for
the road before we head back so
you know we get another round of drinks
or whatever and about that time there
was this hellacious
explosion
i mean
big time explosion
incoming incoming and it wasn't
on our side we could tell it was on the
other side
and we kind of looked at each other you
know like what in the world was that you
know and then you know it was a ensuing
you know then you could
begin hearing things happening
and uh you know we're trying to figure
out what what should we do you know
every our weapon
web gear everything is on the other side
and so we did yeah we did what any good
sf guy would do we said let's just sit
here and have another drink deep you
know this will work its way out you know
somehow this problem will take care of
itself and then we can you know we can
go about our way you know so we uh
we did just that and then finally we
made our way back across the road back
to
the other side and made our way to our
hooch and what had happened was a rocket
had been fired by the into the compound
and it had landed just outside
the doors to our hooches more more on
his than mine
and um
pretty much demolished
his hooch all together
and there was somebody one of his
roommate was inside as i recall and and
received a lot of shrapnel wounds
uh and the ceiling collapsed down on the
bed and
they had some bookshelves nailed to the
walls and anyway it was
i think i've seen pictures of it i
remember it it was it was bad yeah had
john been in the bed asleep yeah and
likewise myself my side of things was
not a lot better off right you know i
had fewer things in there and so there
wasn't quite the mess but i had i nailed
up an ammo box on my wall to put books
in and you know there's a few things and
all that was was messed up
um blown off the wall blown off the wall
yeah and there were you know there were
as some people like to describe them
gaping holes
you know where there shouldn't be gaping
holes
you know and so i assume that had i been
there it would have been
i don't know but it wouldn't you know
you would have been severely
wounded if not killed all right yeah for
the sake john would have been dead
because he would have been crushed right
and for this you know i took some i
suppose literary license here in the
naming one lucky day and for this you
know for the sake of for the sake of the
discussion we can say i escaped
you know with with whatever if you were
a captain
there's no doubt about that there's no
doubt in my mind that i would have died
with regards to the helicopter thing
the centipede i don't know he wasn't
hungry so you well well no if he if
you've actually bitten me i i
i'm not sure his venom would have killed
me but i probably would have died of
fright indeed you know because that's
just not you'll be both
not something you dream of having happen
uh
and then with regards to the rocket uh i
don't know
you know yeah but let's just say i had a
lucky a very lucky day
very lucky day
yeah so with all this um
how did your quest in life
lead you to this moment i mean at some
point in time yeah uh you're you you're
you're a california lad growing up there
in sunny california southern california
yes oxnard oxford indeed and then from
there at some point you go off to
college yeah which was very intense in
the education right but at some point
there's this quest or
what
how would jordan peterson put it for
like as you're looking forward into your
life how did i join the quest yes indeed
that's a good question and i think it's
a you know it's it's one that
probably every special forces person you
talked to would have
an interesting story and they and they
would have some similarities as jordan
peters would say there's something kind
of
universal about these kinds of things as
to what motivate people to do certain
kinds of things but yeah i grew up in in
in oxnard california had gone to grammar
school in high school in the same place
my father was a welder i came from a
decidedly middle class family and they
did my mother worked
and they did what parents did a lot of
parents did they worked and suffered
saved their money so that i could go to
school i was the first one in the
families either side to go to college
wow is that right yes i went up to
college in the bay area at st mary's
college of california
and i got a degree in philosophy of all
things
uh and and in in the course of that i
also spent a year in paris studying at
the university of paris
um so
you know i came back from that
and uh was you know
my father this is a true story my father
he worked at the point magoo naval
shipyard he was a welder and it was also
the headquarters of the pacific missile
range where they fired missiles out into
the ocean to track them and whatever
they did with them
anyway he was he'd worked there for a
long time and so
he had a he had me
that he'd spent all this money on
thinking that i knew
he hoped i was going to be a lawyer or
something useful and instead i get a
degree in philosophy
and so he goes into the civilian
personnel office at appointment gu yeah
and he has this meeting with a guy they
have tom coker and he
he didn't know tom but he says more or
less he says tom i've got this son
that
done this but he doesn't really i don't
know what you know he needs a job
you know and i don't know what he's
qualified to do
anyway tom wonderful man
became a close friend over the course of
years
and
i had an interview with him and he hired
me and so that was where i was working
when the vietnam war really began you
know that was the year of the draft
and you know it was apparent that one
way or the other i was going to probably
become involved my father wanted me to
join the air force because he thought
that was safer
i didn't want to do that and that gets
into this business
i was a philosophy student and many of
the listeners out there may be aware of
this the philosophy the popular
philosophy of that time was
existentialism
you know and the whole point of it was
that you were you
you were became what you did
and that you know the important thing
for a person in life
was to gather as many experiences as
they could and
experiences in areas that were important
and critical that was also like a new
way of thinking yeah it was at least
publicly people talk about in colleges
were picking it up yeah yeah and so you
know i thought well
you know it's clear that you know of all
of the experiences that humanity has
been through over the course of its
existence warfare is pretty common
you know maybe the most common thing so
that's something one ought to have some
nodding acquaintance with you know at
least a nodding you're not exchanging so
i
so i volunteered you know to go in i was
a volunteer my my name my number ra one
eight four eight six four seven
all right uh there i am
and um
i was
going and and when i went to do it the
recruiter told me do i have a deal for
you
he said we're gonna have the first ever
all college graduate infantry officer
candidate class
he said the entire class is going to be
made of nothing but
but college graduates wow and i can get
you in on this
and i thought well yeah infantry i mean
that's what warfare is about it's on the
ground yeah manoa mano or whatever you
know an infantry yeah so i was gonna you
know so i set off
and um
first i did basic trading at fort dix
and i'm proud to say i was the out ten
outstanding training of the cycle no
kidding yeah philosopher king here see i
barely got through fort dix but that's
yeah although i love the story although
i was a philosopher king in the making i
also turned out to be that i could do
you know those things fairly well
so and then i did ait there
and then
where you had to do land navigation
which you were good at yeah that too
and then we were sent then we were moved
to fort benning that was where office
infantry officer candidate school was
and i got started in that
and
some ways into it i got expelled
i got kicked out
and when the commanding officer had me
into his office to tell me this he said
and i
never forgot the words
candidate peters
you have a bad attitude
and i couldn't argue with him okay you
know from your perspective there's no
doubt i have a bad attitude i mean you
know i mean to be awakened at four
o'clock in the morning and have the the
drawer in which you've carefully
arranged your underwear and toothbrushes
and everything else have it dumped onto
the floor you know just to harass you no
that's yeah yeah i developed an attitude
right and before you got thrown out of
ocs wasn't there one night you went awol
oh yes yeah they were filming that's
really important though oh yeah because
this yeah this plays a role in it they
were they were filming the movie the
green beret at fort benning with john
wayne with john wayne
and everybody knows that movie it's
world famous and uh
i would one of the people who was in
officer candidate school with me was
thomas mahan
a really crazy guy
who didn't get kicked who did not get
kicked out of ocs which i still can't
account for to this day
but
he he wanted to be an actor in fact at a
poet he was both he went on to have some
success in that but anyway he says to me
says hey john he says uh
let's crash the
the uh
the cast party yeah he said i've heard
that they're having a cast party tonight
i know where it is
he says why don't we go
and i said no come on you're you're
joking he said no come on let's go so we
went awol from ocs
that night for part of the night and we
went to where the cast party was and
there was the cast from
from filming for that were filming uh
the movie john wayne was not there i
can't claim that
i saw john wayne he was off doing
something else but i sat a good portion
of the night next to his son pat wayne
who's a class act class act and he and i
had a nice conversation you know and
uh you know
[Music]
we couldn't talk about a lot but i know
we got along drink some drinks together
and then we tom and i snuck back into
the ocs barracks and without being
caught without being caught good
training
so when i was kicked out of ocs then
they put you in what they call a casual
company
in which they don't know what to do
either those are the those are the
misfits that they're not really can't
figure out what to do with and so while
they're trying to figure that out they
put you in this place and all you do is
is uh detail work you go out and pick up
cigarette butts you paint stuff paint
stones you do all kinds of meaning yeah
all kinds of meaningless stuff
and so that's where i was you know and i
didn't like that
you know and while they were trying to
figure out what they were going to do
with me i was trying to figure out what
did i want to do with myself yeah we're
back to this kind of a thing you know
sure you know and and in life you find
yourself in those situations you know
you have free will you can make choices
and and and the important issue becomes
what choices do you make i mean you know
i could have i mean
i wouldn't have but had they offered me
the opportunity to be a cook i wouldn't
have taken it you know he offered me to
be a truck driver i wouldn't have taken
it
well
on
at fort benning as some people may know
is where the airborne school is
you know and i'd seen these dudes
walking around with their
their fatigues tucked into their high
top boots into the cochrans yeah they're
[ __ ] holly spitz shine and i thought wow
that looks pretty cool
you know and so i said well
i think i'll do that
you know
i'd like to learn how to jump out
airplanes i think that would be kind of
neat
so anyway so i went to uh airborne
school and uh once again i became an
honor graduate i was an honor graduate
from geneva school jump school i have
said something i have the letter to
prove it indeed
and uh anyway so
when i was nearing the end of jump
school of course then
you know in the military you're
constantly faced with where you're going
to be assigned what you should do next
and so that was i was coming up to that
decision you know i was i got to be with
101st airborne was i going to be what
was i going to do you know well i i
remembered the green beret
i never i hadn't read the book
i heard the i heard the uh song i liked
the song yeah pretty inspiring
um and so i thought well
i'll do that
you know that seems like i mean that
seems from what i hear from what i hear
yeah that's heavy duty you know let's do
that so yeah i volunteered to to for
special forces and was accepted
and
down to brag i went
you know and then
got involved with that you know but here
you did not get the honor graduate award
because absolutely not i mean this is
another one of those things in life that
life could throw at you you know i i was
there and i don't know how many weeks i
was into the whole business
when there was
when there was a training accident
which is not funny because a young guy
was killed uh you know and i think it
was a repelling kind of thing they were
doing it i think it involved repelling
out of a helicopter or what but anyway
he was killed and a contributing factor
maybe that must have been the major
contributing factor is dying was because
he he wore glasses
and so the commanding officer said all
immediately all those who
wear glasses are out
in training group out
so in this cycle i was out yeah you know
one day i'm in next day i'm out
you know and um
yeah i could understand why you know why
they might feel that way i mean yeah you
don't wanna you know i could see where
there was dangers involved i needed
glasses without my glasses i
was pretty well blind
um so then i go into the back into
another casual company
now they're trying to figure out now
you're a brag dog yeah yeah i'm bragging
they're trying to you know they're
trying to figure out what to do with me
i'm trying to figure out to do what with
me yeah yeah um
the good thing was i suppose is that
they said you know they realized this
was a raw deal i mean you know that they
that was really
i would get the shaft i wouldn't yeah
yeah they wouldn't call it tragic but
they said you know it's a bad deal to do
this to people and there were a half a
dozen or a dozen of us i don't know how
many and so they more or less said to us
whatever you want to do we will arrange
that you can do that you know if you
want to go to europe fine we'll send you
to europe if you want to go under our
armor okay or artillery whatever you
want to do you know we'll take care of
you
and i said no i want to go to vietnam i
said you know that's what this is all
about you know i was going to vietnam
and so
i volunteered to go to vietnam
and you landed in vietnam at cameron bay
yeah and guess what i go into
the holding casual company casual
company there yeah going to the casual
company there you know
um
had my records you know and everything
else and so of course uh and as is often
the case you know in the military
you know
some
spec four e4 is in charge of your
destiny indeed you're like this guy this
guy is sitting behind a a
card table you know with people lined up
and he's kind of you know playing god oh
you're going to the 101st you're going
here you're going there you know it's
like the mythology where you know
the god sits there and nods which way
whether you're going to survive or not
and so
he opened up my record says oh you're
coming from bragg i said yeah he said oh
good i'll send you the fifth special
forces group
i said okay with glasses with glasses
yes
i mean that's the ultimate irony is i
wound up doing probably worse things or
more dangerous things than that general
ever thought of indeed and with my
glasses on but anyway so i go to um
you know i get sent there and then
that's when i encounter at
the danang i guess it was that's where
it happened was it tonight where did it
happen that you got the you got the
offer
um well at the end of tr at the end of
your in-country training
you'd be asked for volunteers and then
the volunteers would be shipped to da
nang for your pre-sog briefing yeah
signed the paper well i had none of that
i went so your experience was well i
went out of i went out of the this
casual company to wherever i went and
there i was
uh and and somebody is saying to me and
again the details i can't recall it
again this is early 68 1968 yeah and
essentially somebody said to me
do i have it he said you really want the
deal i mean you you know you want
you want to really do something super
duper you know you really want to be the
man you think you are yeah oh yeah sure
he said okay i've got it for you i said
well great what is this i can't tell you
to you say yes
i said what he said yeah he said this
thing is so
you know it gives that look yeah yeah
it's so top secret right he did i don't
think he even used the word oh he
couldn't yeah he couldn't he was just he
just looked yeah no no no you got to
trust me on this way you got to trust me
on this yes
he says raise your right hand he says
just say yes and i'll tell you and then
you're in
i said okay i'm in
and so you know that's when they then
take you to the next level in which
you're into this room and i think there
were about six of us
that's all yeah it said yes you get the
famous map treatment yeah and then then
it's then it's like again out of some
kind of a maybe a
i don't know what kind of a movie but
there's a there's a on the wall is
something behind a
curtain yeah you know
and uh first of all we sit at the table
and the first thing you have to do is
get your code name your secret code name
oh yeah it's like getting your secret
ring
you know and so
they had he throws a bunch of cards you
know on on the table which had
names
you know code names already on them yeah
and most of the guys said okay yeah yeah
they picked up one one guy
this is very politically incorrect but
anyway
he was black and he picked the code name
halloween oh no
okay so you know i looked through
the ones and none of them really
appealed to me so i said can i pick my
own he said sure yeah pick your own so i
picked my pascal who was a french
philosopher who indeed who i was
uh meant a lot to me so anyway that was
my
code name so after we got our code and
then oh and then they bring in the thing
that you sign that you're not gonna
spill you know you're never gonna talk
about this for 20 years yeah whatever it
was for the pain yeah and i don't know
what they were going to do to you but
they
implied that it was going to be bad you
know so we signed that
what else did you do but the other thing
they well that was that they told you
put away your pads and and pens because
there's no notes
yeah yeah in other words you get the big
setup and then a colonel came in you had
a colonel yeah okay
i only had a sergeant major that's okay
i think the sergeant major did the first
stuff but then when it got to the
pulling back of the curtain we needed a
heavy hitter up there indeed so the
colonel came in and ripped back
the uh the cartoon you know
and i i looked at it you know and i said
why am i looking at a map of the san
joaquin valley yeah that's all it looked
like here you look like it because
vietnam reminded you okay
california i said why am i looking at
you know
what in the world is are they gonna ship
me home to do some you know yeah pick up
lettuce or something
no then he said you know this is
this is laos cambodia and south vietname
goes through the whole thing and he
tells you you know this is what you got
to do and you're going to run missions
across here and they're top secret and
you know
can't tell your mama yeah you can't tell
anybody and everything else and so
yeah then that's it you know i go
outside and they put me on a helicopter
to fubai welcome to fubai yeah i like
food by and i virtually know no more
when i land in fuba than i do did when i
left
fort benning you know really i was
you know welcome to the secret award
yeah the last official training i'd
received with jumping out of airplanes
the rest of it was all serendipitous
you know but again we laugh but i mean
i'd like to bring it back to that issue
that you know sure along the way i had
free will i could have selected anything
i wanted to do or said no to anything i
didn't want to do
but no no i had in mind
something that i thought it was
important for me to do experience learn
and so i said yes
and i think that
would probably be you know
many of people in special ops and those
kinds of people i think have parallel
experiences
they may not have been as conscious of
it as i was because of my philosophy
background if you will or whatever but
yes i was conscious of what i was doing
but i think operative underneath
all of it was the same kind of stuff we
grew up and this is a jordan peterson
thing i think all of us that got
involved in that
grew up with one kind of a hero or
another
you know we had in uh from early on
we had heroes somebody we wanted to live
up to somebody we wanted to emulate it
could have been our father it could have
been a neighbor it could have been
superman it could have been
murphy hop along cassidy i don't know
uh i had hopalong cassidy twin pistols
at one time
uh which
obviously you know i was at the i think
with chaps and of course yeah i think i
was about
seven years old or something there's
exists a picture of me with a hoppy hat
on the whole thing um but anyway you
know i think that gets ingrained into
you somewhere along the line and then
from then on
in a deep-seated way nothing will do
except that you do it
and that if you don't you will live for
the rest of your life with a kind of
disappointment that will haunt you and
self yeah yeah
um you know it
it might not lead to anything
catastrophic it just will you will have
a constant gnawing sensation
that there was an opportunity you missed
and that had you taken that opportunity
you would have somehow been better off
for having done it yeah you know and i
think all of us who were in sog
risks stupidities and all involved
because let's face it it was it was a
there were aspects of the song mission
which were blatantly stupid
i mean what they were having us do under
the conditions they were having us do it
with so little intelligence and so
chance of such small chance often
pulling off the mission and then once
you did of that of the consequences of
whatever it was you brought back having
any measurable effect whatsoever or if
it did you wouldn't even be told yeah
you wouldn't know about it yeah so i
mean yeah it was just it was it was a
weird thing to be a part of indeed you
know and uh
so you landed foo by and the first thing
you land on is a hatchet force right yes
welcome to fuba and yeah so a hatchet
force at that time
uh would you remember which company it
was no but it was a hatchet force and
the hatchet force company had fubai yeah
and that was your platoon i think they
were company sizes
they had a company with platoon size
operations
and we didn't go across the fence at
least i didn't go across the fence with
them we'd go out and and other kinds of
in-country kinds of search and destroy
type things most of it was training
because the the indigenous people were
cambodians
and oh yeah they were kim and they were
i hope there's no cambodians in the
audience but they were not good um they
were
hard to train and they were hard for
they wore around their necks what they
call their buddha bag it was on a
thong a leather thong and it was a
literally kind of a little leather bag
in which they kept
you know various things that brought
them a luck
and whenever you would get into an
intense firefight of some kind they
would lay down on the ground and put
their buddha bag in their mouth
you know and that was going to save
their lives and in most cases at work
because when you're lying on the ground
you know you're fairly safe as long as
you're not getting overrun yeah you know
that's pretty good
but anyway it got so bad that
all of them were literally without any
notice rounded up do you remember that
day
vaguely yeah they were all rounded up in
no prior
knowledge of this whatsoever the entire
group of
cambodias and i don't know how many
there were 125 or something like that
they were marched to the gator of the
compound and off the compound with only
what they could carry
and my understanding is from there they
were put on some kind of transportation
that took them back
to where they came from indeed and that
kind of put you know that certainly
because there have been a couple of
firefights in in on base that involved
the cambodians with the either the
brewer the vietnamese right none of whom
liked each other all of whom
hated each other more than yeah well
that kind of crimped the style of the
batch force yeah because now at that
point yeah they just got rid of you know
the majority of their people
and then i then i went to recon and you
landed on rhode island rhode island was
one of the premier recon teams and the
1-0 was
les daniels indeed
uh what a tiger yeah i don't know what
portion of him was uh indian american
indian but whatever it was he carried it
fully in his blood i mean that man had
instincts
he did he was not a man of great humor i
mean he was no he was not somebody you
could ch i never i never got to know him
in the sense of knowing somebody because
he was very quiet you know but very he
could give you those eyes
oh yeah you know if you did something
wrong
you know and he all that's all he had to
do was look at you you know you thought
oh god yeah you knew yeah yeah but
and then i went to uh i was in the first
1-0 class
that was held oh is that right yeah yeah
i don't know how i got involved with
that but again i uh got involved one
zero school is a reconnaissance team
leader school it was called and
so i went down and went through
reconnaissance team leader school so
that was an interesting experience very
and um there's a little disorganized
badger jeffrey junkins as a picture yes
yeah if you all like at some portion of
the training if not the actual
graduation yeah you guys no no there was
no room for graduation this was the
first class and i must say it was kind
of disjointed i understand that it
really developed into something a lot
better it did but you know but at that
first class there was a little bit of a
disjunction
but that we enjoyed it we spent a lot of
time in the club uh and telling stories
and and
that reminds me because uh you know we
you and i encounter special forces guys
today and i think they have a hard time
believing that we did what we did one
and then we were so young and so
inexperienced and given so much
uh responsibility sure and that there
was
we were we were winging it literally
there was no
guy this was not the mission of special
forces was not to run recon right you
know and and again correct me if i'm
wrong but my understanding is it was
called command and control to set it
apart from any other kind of special
forces activity we commanded and
controlled we didn't advise
you know most special forces operations
and involve some
kind of advising of a
counter-revolutionary source or
something yeah we didn't do that we
commanded our troops
and so
we did train him up we did train him up
of course he had less with less though
oh what a premier he's probably the best
1-0 in camp at that time well aside from
yourself well no no i wouldn't no no he
was a far exceeded anything i ever did
on the ground he was amazing man yeah he
was something absolutely but uh yeah so
we were at uh 1-0 school and um
you know then
going from there yeah you ran a few
missions with les yeah and then by was
it
like
at the end of october or early november
or some point there's a crisis and
somebody comes to john peters
and says
hey how about cleaning up this little
deficit of 25 thousand missing from the
club funds
that was another one of those totally
unexpected things
the former club manager whose name we
shall not use
yeah
and i don't know whether he did anything
illegal or whether he stole we just know
he spent a lot of money yeah it's all we
know is that suddenly the club well we
can't say that everybody who was a green
beret there did come home with a brand
new
specially tailored sports coat i didn't
i had mine for years we'll see you
weren't in with the outcrowd or you
weren't out with the in crowd whatever
it was i never got a green sport
but anyway so you know they suddenly
discovered that the club is 25 000 in
debt yeah and they're about to close fob
right and they don't want this to come
out you know because part of the closing
ceremonies i guess or the process or
whatever they thought there's going to
be i don't know some kind of an audit i
beats me
but
you know
again it's a magical mystery tour we're
in a top secret operation where nobody
knows what the hell is really going on
yeah we're going to close the base but
don't tell anybody yeah and when we
close it oh it could clean up this 25
000 deficit i think we all discovered
that that's one of the great advantages
of top secrets you can get away with
anything
and then say and say i'm sorry i can't
tell you about that
but
anyway so we had a meeting in the club
and you tell me you don't remember this
too clearly but i certainly do we're in
the club and you know
uh the sergeant major whoever was harris
harris is telling us of the bad news
yeah and what he considers to be bad
news i didn't consider it bad news i
don't care it didn't come out of your
body come out of my pocket so i didn't
really care
so anyway but he's saying this is
serious we got to do something about it
okay yeah yeah
and so we need somebody to come in and
and take over you know so to speak
and straighten all this mess out and
somehow recover from this 25 thousand
dollar deficit and i would say oh
about 35 minutes
no there was a deadline you know so that
was the deadline so everybody kind of
looks around at everybody else
and to this day i don't know who it was
somebody says peter still it let peters
do it
you know
maybe it was because
i don't know why maybe because it was i
was a college graduate and they
therefore assumed i was good at math
i don't know you know but i was a
philosopher i wasn't a mathematician you
know so anyway they say
so in short order i made i am made club
manager yeah of the club you know which
was a
significant
thing it was i mean it was very
important to us to those who were family
who'd go in there and drink it was
extremely important
and so there i was you know i didn't
have a clue as to what it meant to be a
club manager
and uh you know the rest is history
we did recover it it took some
creative
i remember the flavor of the club
changed and it became more efficient all
of a sudden yeah right yeah right
if you're going to get a drink you pay
for it that's right other times you
might just get away with it
and if
and we started using shot glasses for
the first time we're measuring this
stuff out and we had the vietnamese
girls working back
and they were used to being pretty free
with stuff
not just liquor and uh you know so
so i had to get them on board you know
look
your boyfriend comes in here no we're
not emptying half the bottle into his
glass you know we're going to do this
but the big the big money the big money
maker was if you remember this we had
access to booze that nobody else had
yeah you know we have slot machines we
once had a helicopter bring in a
container load of it you remember that
no yeah he brought a container load of
stuff in and set it down in the compound
i mean we're talking is that the king be
the crashed in the compound that time no
but anyway okay i mean this is this is
well this is yeah this is a major
delivery service in major goods
and of course
there weren't enough of us in the
compound to use this no my plan was to
sell it to the 101st airborne division
guys down the road and of course you had
a friendly marines be willing at least
the officers that flew those guys too
yeah of course anybody who wanted booze
we were open for business here we go and
it you know it cost us about a dollar a
bottle for it or something like that as
i recall that's what i sold it to our
own guys yeah it was for a buck is that
right yeah but for anybody else
uh you know uh
sky is the limit and so that's how we
you know how we managed to do it
but i mean the worst part in the world
you know everybody thinks oh boy being
club managers god that's got to be great
because there was a little room attached
to the club that the car manager got to
that was where he lived i know it and it
was remembered it was air-conditioned it
was small but it was it was comfortable
and everybody thought you know i'd kill
for that and so i i thought wow i'm a
lot landed on my feet here you know
until the first night at 11 o'clock or
two no about one o'clock in the morning
there's this horrendous pounding on the
door peters peter's open up i want a
six-pack you know
you know i said you open them give them
a six pack you know three minutes later
bang bang bang peters peters i want a
bottle of scotch okay
and this goes on night after night
afternoon and you're making up a deficit
and i'm making up a debt boy oh boy
and did it indeed indeed so uh you go to
kantoom
at some point in 69 you're done with the
army in 69 or 70. and then 69 may have
69. may 69. wow we missed each other by
a month yeah indeed okay so then you're
out and then what happens next as you go
on with your life quest oh my life quest
well i came back
and um took up the job the one that i
had that my father got for me at
appointment gu what were you doing
exactly a point with goo i was what they
call the labor management relations
specialist i was involved with yeah i
was involved with dealing with the
unions
and doing stuff like that it was it was
quite interesting anybody i went back uh
and they they
they didn't do it i don't think out of
the goodness of their heart they
required by law to hold the job for
right because i was in the military so i
went back and and you went into the army
yeah had a navy job yeah i
didn't i didn't mention that
well we couldn't talk about anything and
no you know and i don't know about you
but i mean you know people hear about
the environment
vietnam veterans return
in 1968 69. oh yeah he was hostile
i mean
the only i mean i never you hear stories
of people spitting on you and all that
kind of stuff with people and i i don't
don't want to say it didn't happen it
didn't happen to me but the one thing
that did happen is i
processed out at oakland
and so i
you know i'd gone to school in the bay
area at st mary's and so i knew it well
and so i went back over to san francisco
side and i wanted to celebrate and i but
all i had was a uniform my beret and a
uniform on
and i wanted to go to the top of the
mark to have a drink and and look out
over the city and i thought yeah yeah
this is this would be neat and so i do
and i get into the helicopter and the
helicopter i get into the elevator
and you know we start up there's another
young couple in there and the look they
gave me they didn't say anything
you know they didn't really treat me
badly but i mean you could tell that i
was as far as they were concerned about
as low as you could get lower than snail
sniper yeah and i get to the top and the
matriarch the guy who they says you
can't come in
will yeah i said no i'm sorry
won't let you in so i had to turn around
and go back down again
it was yeah
i wasn't
i was disappointed but i wasn't
heartbroken you know yeah
so i went home and um took up that job
and i but i
at that point i was kind of restless and
there was still more i wanted to do so i
quit the job
and returned to europe and uh hitchhiked
around i hitchhiked from paris to
tangier
to tangier yeah tangier and a famous two
weeks lost of my life tonight that i
cannot recount to this day nor do you
want to baby i don't well i don't know
maybe it may be something i really like
to remember i don't know but no and then
yeah and then
the rest of my life has been that kind
of a thing i've
i've given up a number of very good jobs
that would have been career jobs because
okay well you you got to allow me to
return to this excellent book on the
ground
because there's a little portion in
there where we talked about there's a
couple things i always found really
fascinating about you
that
you know
at some point you became the owner's
representative
and port captain
in damon damon the mom damon thank you
saudi arabia right for the american
steamship company pacific east
far east lines
yeah and then for 15 years you manage
the u.s air force's aerial port
at ronstein germany ramstein germany
that too yeah
just tell us a little bit about i mean
those jobs i mean
in in germany and then you're in saudi
arabia at least yeah just a little bit
this is well i said i'd gone to saint
mary's college and
one of the people that i in fact roomed
with for a while was
john aliotto whose father joe aliotta
senior was the mayor of san francisco
and uh
and
at some point i i got it i got a job at
the alameda naval air station again in
labor management relations and i was
working there
and joe aliotto senior bought a
steamship company for his son
oh how nice yeah pacific far east lines
one of the oldest steamship companies in
the united states american flag
steamship it was an american flag
company
and they operated off of the pacific
coast into uh into the pacific and they
had passed they had the last two
passenger vessels the monterey and the
mariposa
and they operated up to alaska and took
uh people to hawaii and things like that
uh the cargo operations went to
australia new zealand
japan places like that and so it was
really a far eastern operation
uh but this is this is in the early 70s
and saudi
saudi arabia was just booming you know
we had the first oil embargo remember of
course and they were rolling in money
and they were you're they're a part of
the audience yeah they don't they were
rolling in money and they were wanting
they were spending it like there was no
tomorrow and so there was an awful lot
of
stuff being hauled to saudi arabia so
john elliot and oh well what happened
was i'm i'm at right i skipped over this
i'm at alameda naval air station when i
get a call
from john aliotto saying
how'd you like to be
working a steamship company
and i said john i know nothing about
steam sips he says nor do i
he was a he was a poet and failed play
pl uh playwright he'd written this play
called the black mass and his father had
arranged to have it enacted put on or
whatever you want to call it in san
francisco and it was an abysmal failure
so that i mean that that's the love
that's the guy that now running a
shipping company yeah president of
pacific far east lines so he says you
know
yeah i said well i don't know come on
over and let's do it i said okay so i
quit the job that i had in alameda and
crossed over the bay to the other side
and went to work for pfel not knowing
anything so they they put me through
kind of a break this sounds just like
your sf career yeah they put me through
this kind of introductory program of
what it was what it meant to be a and
the steamship you know the front end is
called the bow you know the back end is
called the stern you know which one's
the port i always get that
port the left side
important
starboard to
bath the beam and all these things you
know that you got no
and uh and not to mention bulkheads
bulkheads i don't know those that's the
one that throws me off yeah yeah
baby dog yeah anyway
um
so you know i'm i'm going along learning
the ropes when suddenly i get again and
get this call from the head office
you know
and it was really just down the hall
yeah i was and john says
how'd you like to be the port captain in
damon saudi arabia owner's
representative
i i had no idea what that meant
yeah
could you interpret that put that in
english like what does that mean
they i knew that the company had
invested in two new vessels
uh to run out of baltimore through the
suez canal
to saudi arabia uh the gulf baron the
atlantic bear i think they were called
yeah there was there were roll-on
roll-off ships and so i knew we'd we
were into this venture and i'd heard
that was going well because it was a
good market
um but i didn't really know that much
about it and so anyway yeah then i was
put on an airplane and flown to saudi
arabia
and um put in charge of you know
representing the company that we had we
had an actual agent there who did a lot
of the work but at that time the
headquarters for that operation that was
the middle east gulf operations was in
tehran
and really yeah the shah was still in
and sure so i went to tehran a number of
times i worked ships out of kuwait abu
dhabi
uh dubai boundary abbas panda shapur so
when you say you work the ship doesn't
mean you help get the ship in the port
unload it get it unloaded or get it
loaded or what does that mean i mean
mostly it meant that i stood around and
looked like i knew what i was doing oh
you had a clipboard yeah did you think
again more or less like that no i
mean no they would uh on roll-on
roll-off ships those are ships that you
can drive the car go on to okay you know
either yeah
they're really big boats oh yeah and
they look like aircraft carriers they
really did when they went to the cs
canal they sometimes got challenged for
being aircraft carriers but they weren't
um
but they would have bulldozers and they
would have trackhoes and they would have
all kinds of big heavy equipment on them
dump trucks and stuff like that yeah
plus uh
containers that were on the chassis that
would be taken off and put back on again
um and we we would fly over a crew of
four drivers
who would do that but no essentially i i
was the liaison between the the captain
of the ship whenever came off the ship
yeah and the agent and whatever was
going on there and uh yeah
but some you know some really uh so for
how many years oh just for a year
and then the germany no
it took a while to do that
it took a while no but you know some
really remarkable things happened while
i was there the biggest one was that um
we had another kind of ship called the
lash ship which was lighter aboard ship
and what it had to have these huge
barges and had a 500 ton traveling crane
that would that would travel the length
of the ship the ships were 900 feet long
and it would go out it had some rails
that ran out over the transom which is
another name for the
career
and it would it could pick up these
barges and they were stacked on the
board and the concept was that the
vessel would lie off at a distance and
if the waters were too shallow
stuff would go on the
barges and tugs would take them in
well one of the ships came in it was the
uh pacific bear
came in and he lost steerage something
happened and he really he
it wasn't it wasn't steerage he lost he
he couldn't reverse
his engines and so couldn't
really effectively stop and one of those
vessels probably takes a mile you know
to stop once they decide they're going
to
and so
we had to do something about that so i
had to hire a tug to go out to
help
maneuver the
vessel where it needed to be
and in the process
the tug was uh capsized
and uh
life was lost
and the saudis immediately impounded the
ship which meant it couldn't sail
and the cost of those ships was
calculated to be two thousand dollars an
hour
an hour hour and so this is 1971 or two
yeah and so there we were um you know
and
that was a really something
in fact
two i think was two years later when i
was it no it was
longer than that it was maybe i don't
know it was quite a bit later because i
was in germany
when they finally had the trial
in san francisco to assess blame because
the
pfao was sued for negligence
and
they flew me back from germany to
testify in the trial but yeah
no kidding yeah
whoa
i said then on to germany what took you
a while to get there no because then i
then i did nothing in
in san francisco for a while i'm very
good at doing nothing
and
my my future wife marlo was there in san
francisco with me and she's a librarian
and uh
she finally decided that she wanted
wanted i we weren't married she decided
that she wanted to leave san francisco
that the time had gone she'd been there
five years
so she was offered the job of librarian
at um in spokane washington at
at fairchild air force base which is a
cargo operation for the then it was
called the military airlift command so i
went up there and again was doing
nothing i was a kept man
marlo was you know and so
we were there for a year we got married
there and we were there for a year and a
half two years and
so she applied for a job in germany as a
librarian and she got the job
and so
um
she went to germany and because i was
her dependent indeed and so she had to
go without me
until she found a place for us to live
and then i could fly and join her as if
you know and i did
and i took the first job i could get was
the title the literal title was wg2
laborer
laborer
and
manual labor i picked things up and put
them down
and and i worked in the aerial port just
like an elder sun mission yeah it was
just similar
in in the cargo operation for the six or
eighth aerial port squadron
and after six months i think it was i
was promoted to a forklift driver
this was a big day in my life indeed
yeah and i got to climb on a flight did
you get a little training for b1 with
our forklift there no no okay anyway i
climbed the board through a beard never
mind climbed aboard the forklift and
went to work yeah and then the really
bizarre thing happened
because
another bizarre thing okay
because the military left
command decided that the squadron
operations office well at that time it
was called the air terminal manager
was a lieutenant colonel's position
but though like in the military they
rotated out every two years or so there
would be a new one so sure they saw that
there was lost continuity that there was
certain things about the operation that
the you know that the incoming
oper aerial air terminal manager would
not know right so they needed some form
of continuity so decided they would have
a civilian
assistant
air terminal manager
of almost the equivalent rank it was my
the rank was the cover of a major but it
was a civil service position
and so
i decided that i was going to apply for
this job you know but certainly civil
service regulations were that in order
for me to apply for the job i had to
quit
that you somehow couldn't move from what
the
the laboring people were wearing a
weight structure called
wage gray structure wlg i was a wg2
whereas the other position i'm going to
is the gs which everybody hears about
the gs kind of that portion of the
system yeah and you couldn't move from
one to the other while you were employed
in the lower i don't know that's what i
was told
so i had to quit with no guarantee i was
going to be hired hired and they uh i
was told that they advertised the job
and they had
32 applicants from afar's way to japan
but none of them had philosophy degrees
that's right that was it that was it
so i got selected uh for the job
i've been working with these guys yeah i
started with them as a w as a laborer
sure
wound up being a forklift driver you
know and there were 60 in in the aerial
port squadron there were
uh
uh
60 non uh non-us personnel and they were
germans italians
british
turkish
greek
all kinds of people mixed that was one
set of the workforce the other was
americans
and there were 15 or 20 of those who
knew me as a fellow worker so they saw
me leave
as
they didn't know why i left they just
saw me leave one day
and then i come back as the boss with a
new hat yeah so i went from i went from
janitor to executive vice president
you know
and they they really didn't know what to
deal with that and how to deal with that
so that yeah oh i love it that got me
that indeed so how many years then 15
50. and i finally finally i for the last
of it i was actually
the by that time they changed the title
to squadron operations officer and i was
the squadron operations i was the first
and i think only
a civilian to hold that
position as well okay yeah well sir uh
looks like we're getting pretty close to
two hours here
i told you we go quick amazing and uh as
we get close to this point i know you
got to get back to dresden to your
sweetheart
is there any uh final clothing uh
thoughts
that you'd like to close out with as we
uh come to the end here john well i mean
it expressed the obvious sense of having
had a fortunate and blessed life i mean
not only having lasted at this point but
to along the way to accumulate wonderful
friends like yourself and the others
that that are a part of this that are
tremendously admirable men and you've
interviewed some of them indeed
and just great men and i also want them
a special things to you because i think
it's through your efforts more than any
other i can think of off the top of my
head that song
that the song stories have been told and
told so well
and that they've it's gained the kind of
uh
notice and notoriety if you will that it
has
you know you've really made something of
us you've made us especially proud well
that's been done thanks to jocko
well yeah he was well he contributed but
i mean you wrote you wrote across the
fence indeed and we together we wrote on
the ground but which is much better
written my critics have told me thanks
to you sir no but i mean yeah don't
don't you know don't play this down
you've had you've been a remarkably
positive
element in in all of our lives and so
thank you very much
thank you to whatever gods may be for
having me here and indeed
to my lovely wife we just celebrated our
43rd wedding anniversary last sunday and
you've known her for how many years 50
we're good august of this year it'll be
50 years it took you seven years to wise
up to get the popped the big question
yeah
i love her but you did it
she's a wonderful woman i love her she
is well we're closing that good note and
as we close out i want to thank all of
our veterans out there including men
like john peters who have fought for the
ideals of our country truly one of our
american heroes
to those of you out there on the front
lines now
we thank you for fighting for all
that are part of our ideals we want to
thank the police also law enforcement
border patrol
secret service paramedics dispatchers
corrections officers
and of course all of our service members
whether you serve in the army navy
marine corps air force coast guard or
now the space force
and with that we thank you all again and
i thank jocko for making these sog casts
possible very much
and for those of you who
and for those who couldn't come home the
stories that have not yet been told we
we render a final salute and we'll end
on that note